Today We Gather that lukashenko has
confirmed that yevgenie pregosian the
leader of the Wagner group is now in
Belarus
yes he has um I think he's still talking
he likes to talk at considerable length
when he gets the chance Alexander
lukashenko and he's gone into quite a
lot of detail about his uh dealings with
lukashenko sorry with pig origin on
Saturday as you say he says that the
Wagner leader is now in Belarus but
Wagner forces are not he says they're
still in lugansk in the donbass in
eastern Ukraine and there was some
reporting that Belarus was already
constructing camps for them and
lukashenko denied that but he said if
they want camps we can build them for
them
um but he said you know my offer to
plygozian was that if you want to crash
in Belarus you can at your own expense
and so that's what he's doing and uh he
talked about the telephone calls that
the two men had on Saturday as the March
for justice as begotten called his march
on Moscow was going on and he said that
at 11 o'clock he first spoke to precogen
and the man was in a pretty much a
frenzy and the first half power was just
packed with expletives the kashenko said
there were 10 times more expletives than
any normal conversation would have had
and that plagoshin having talked to his
men at the front who'd seen vast numbers
of their comrades die was really half
mad had arrived in rostov half mad from
the front and also he mentioned the fact
that those involved in the negotiations
alongside lukashenko were the director
of the FSB Alexander botnikov and the
deputy defense minister who we'd seen
sitting alongside brigajin in rostov
they had apparently broken
um the the decision for lukashenko to uh
to take the lead with Prego and
lukashenko had had to tell Prego you
know Putin is not going to speak to you
you're not even going to have a
telephone call so you're going to have
to be dealing with me some pretty juicy
details there about how the whole
situation was diffused on Saturday and
he is continuing to talk so we'll bring
you more on that um as we get it as you
say Vladimir Putin has also decided to
talk to his Security Forces defense
minister there's a big meeting in the
Kremlin now with his defense ministers
and before that a meeting in the
kremlin's Cathedral Square with around 2
troops and Security Services in front of
him just thanking them for standing
United
for stopping the country from going to
the brink of Civil War I think he felt
that and feels that you know going to
his Security Forces now is a way of
bringing this all to an end I think it's
also a suggestion to anybody within the
security forces
um that uh that that they will not you
know that any
dissonance will not be tolerated but I
expect then from now on after these uh
this series of events today from
Vladimir Putin he'll probably try and
put this whole business behind him and
hope that the questions that the public
have that the questions the elite have
are abated somewhat
um the question is will they be
what about the position of lukushenko
himself I mean in the past Putin's
treated him with Burly disguised
contempt he's emerged as a more
important player in the region after
this hasn't he
well I think that he's still uh very
useful to Vladimir Putin
um and yes I mean he loves moments like
this and yes he's kind of come out of
this looking uh quite good because he's
managed to engineer uh a solution but he
wouldn't have been able to do that
without uh Putin's blessing and without
Putin's Direction I mean lukashenko
since the disputed elections in August
2020 has very much had to do
um Putin's bidding
uh and he and he loves seizing moments
of Glory like this and he's doing so
um I think that's that's that's pretty
much all I can say about the matter you
know what we've seen over the last three
years in the relationship between
Belarus and Russia is that Belarus has
rapidly lost its sovereignty something
that lukashenko over three decades
really tried to maintain and now he's
just happy to have played a role I think